MIN-MIN LIANG: Lingt,
it's an online tool,
so many teachers use it.
You can record your voice.
You can ask your students
to record a voice.
You can assign the speaking
lessons assignment on that.
It's very convenient, because
everybody has a computer.
You don't need to go
to the lab anymore.
So the tooling is created
by two MIT students.
So when they
started, they want us
to participate as a guinea pig.
So it was fun.
What I use for this
class, because I discover,
I usually think in our
class is the time to speak.
I don't like to spend a lot
of time explaining things,
or teach them how
to pronounce words,
because they know the alphabet
part of the [INAUDIBLE]
already.
So I like them to do with
these mechanic works at home.
And in class they
are well prepared
and then we talk
about this lesson.
And I realize that giving
them a quiz of this content
is not enough.
Because I realize
students study, they do.
So they want to do
well in their quiz.
So they read the text,
silently, at home.
So they might know
what it means,
they don't know how
to pronounce it.
So how do I fix that?
Because I used to spend
time, ask everybody
to read one line of the class,
and I encountered this problem.
The kids just-- they can
translate the sentence,
they cannot say the vocabulary
in Chinese when they read it.
They say I know that word, but I
don't know how to pronounce it.
So I-- that's it dawned on
me that they did prepare,
but they not reading
out loud at home.
So they don't know how
to pronounce the words.
If you don't know
how to pronounce it,
you're not learning it.
So I create this-- I
didn't create it, Lingt--
actual assignment
every new lesson,
I ask them to read the
textbook and record
a voice on the Lingt.
Lingt is the web tool.
And send it to me
where I can check.
So I found out
that many students
want to have a perfect
recording, so they will read
10 times before they record it--
which is great, because they
say they memorize the text.
And they know every words,
how to pronounce it.
That's my goal.
So that's how I use it.
I find that I don't need
to spend more time to check
do you know how to pronounce
this words anymore,
because they have to do it.
Yeah, so that's how I use.